today we're going to ask a question when
is 128 bits of encryption 128 bits of
encryption what does that mean is that
good right you know will a quantum
computer affect this there's only a few
years ago used to say military-grade I
mean we all using military-grade
encryption very much so if you're using
256 bit AES it's slightly more minute or
even than 128 but if you're using a hump
rate don't feel bad you're still doing
absolutely fine on a very very simple
level for a symmetric cipher that is a
cipher where we use the same key for
both encryption and decryption so we're
not talking about public key right there
what we usually mean when we say 128 bit
is the length of the key we don't tend
to talk about block size particularly so
128 bit AES is a AES with 128 bit key
you also have 192 and 256 bit variants
of AES they have the same block size but
the key gets longer I have a number of
rounds changes the reason we talk about
the key length particularly is because
if the cipher is good the key is a bit
you don't know the key is a bit you're
going to have to guess so for 128 bit
block cipher you might have to
brute-force through 2 to the power of
128 different keys that's a lot of keys
you might get lucky you might get it
halfway through in which cases to to 127
but I have a way it's not a picnic like
that is years and years and years of
work right much too much work even for
the world's fastest supercomputer
because to 128 is a lot bigger than you
think this only gets harder if we make
these keys bigger so 2 to the 192
operations or 2 to the 256 which is the
number so unimaginably large that let's
just not even worry about it if your
encryption is using a key that's 2 to
256 long and there isn't another issue
with your cipher right so the security
base is based entirely on the key then
that is not brute forcible in it in any
sense we're in the next 10 years within
the next 30 years it's good for us if I
is the case so which of these should be
used well I mean intuitively 256 bit
right but actually 128 bit is currently
out of reach of any attacks but it's
always a slightly more complicated in
this what we also talk about is maybe
the security of an algorithm itself
maybe
there's something in the album but isn't
quite as secure as the key itself so
maybe it wouldn't take to to 128
operations to solve it let's say I've
written a cipher that's got 128-bit key
it may not have 128 bits of security
which is to say it would take this many
operations to solve and that why because
my ciphers not very good maybe it
doesn't mix up things enough or it
doesn't permute enough I don't know
I designed it it's not going to be very
good so you might find that an attack or
a break on something like a AES what
it's doing is not telling me how to
solve that problem
it's just reducing this number so maybe
there's an attack on AES that brings it
from 2 to 128 down to 2 to the 125 or
something like that
now that is many times faster than that
but still totally out of reach right so
that is what I would call an academic
break which is to say we've technically
found a weakness in the underlying our
algorithm but it's not a weakness it
affects me in my everyday life which
arguably is what I care about most so we
wanted a Singlish between the bit length
of the key so when we say we've got
128-bit AES we were phone to the key but
actually the level of security could be
slightly lower depending on the our room
I mean to use a really obvious example
let's imagine I have an algorithm that
just depends the key to the message
doesn't do any encryption at all right
that has a security of zero bits right
because doesn't encrypt anything but it
does have a nice 128-bit key for what
it's worth hey not a very good example
you get the idea if you've got some
fundamental weaknesses in your cipher
it's not going to take a full brute
force to do it booooo forced is the
absolute worst case for an attacker now
this is slightly more confusing for
public key cryptography so things like
RSA and diffie-hellman right because
they tend to have much much bigger keys
so typical diffie-hellman or RSA key
it's going to be somewhere between two
oh four eight three oh seven two or four
oh nine six bits easily a common size is
now two factor and solve the RSA problem
for a three thousand bit key it's
roughly the same as brute forcing
128-bit good symmetric cipher right so
those numbers obviously not even close
to the same so the security margin in
some sense of these is lower for a given
key length right one of the reasons that
elliptic curves
so popular is they get us a little bit
closer from here to here so an elliptic
curve of 256 bits it's going to be
roughly equivalent to the security of
128-bit AES or 3072 bit RSA now that's
going to be quite a lot faster to
compute so it's no longer about the
length of the key in terms of bits it's
about how many bits of security are we
going to get and that means essentially
two to the how many operations are we
going to have to prove force through to
guess or work out what's going on so how
good is 128 bit or 192 or 256 bit and
their equivalents well 2 to 128 bits is
beyond any computer on earth exists but
what you know it's the obvious question
or the kinase coming coming without the
new advent of quantum computing quantum
computing right so one thing that's
meant to make really clear about quantum
computers is they are not simply a very
fast regular computer you don't just run
AES on a quantum computer much faster
than you would do on a normal computer
right and make your life easier you have
specific algorithms that do specific
jobs and the algorithm that makes
breaking AES easier it's called Grover's
algorithm it takes this hypothetically
from 2 to 128 to 2 to the 64 now two to
64 is within reach so if a quantum
computer exists that can break a AES
using Grover's algorithm you're going to
go from 128-bit security to 64-bit
security that is a problem right if you
go from 256 bit security to 2 to the
128th that's less of a problem because
I've already just said that would be on
reach of any computer right so symmetric
is very resistant to quantum computers
because all it does is half the key
space and we can just double the key
space does this quantum computer exist
no will it exist soon not for at least
2025 years is what Robert told me when
we asked it I mean I have no idea I
don't develop these computers but
certainly not anytime soon so public key
cryptography like this 3000 bit RSA key
for example that is much more affected
by quantum computers Shor's algorithm
will basically make this as trivial on a
quantum computer as just encrypting
using RSA would be on a Meg
the computer that's not what you want
right so if a giant quanta computer
appears that can have this problem that
same quantum computer could
theoretically completely destroy RSA
encryption and then we're falling back
on password-based key derivation
functions and symmetric encryption right
that would be the first thing but there
are cryptographers and mathematicians
looking to create quantum resistant
versions of public key algorithms of
which some have been developed right so
the chances are by the time such a
machine exists we won't be using these
because of the fact that they have this
inherent weakness but I mean to be clear
the they have not factored anywhere
close to a 3,000 bit number with quantum
computer yet right there's questions
about whether that's possible because
it's just a scale of the thing but even
if it is it's not going to happen
tomorrow right I mean it'll be quite
amusing if we did and my video is panned
as being horribly outdated day after
release but this isn't going to happen
anytime soon but a good news from our
point of view is we're still going to
get to to 128 bits of security from
aes-256 which is why that's what's
recommended for sort of long-term
security for sort of 30 plus years all
right let's say I'm encrypting my credit
card details and sending him off to an
online shop that credit card will have
expired in two years so it is a honestly
zero interest to me if you break my
credit card details after that card has
been expired all right you're welcome go
go if your government or the NSA or GCHQ
or someone who has top-secret documents
that need to last for over 30 years
then you should be worrying about
whether you use two to 128 or to two to
256 you'll find actually if you go
online based on Microsoft quit looking
around most websites use 128-bit AES
banks and stuff are using 256 I still I
mean arguably that isn't necessary right
now but there's no real reason for them
not to right it's not that much slower
these qubits can interact this guy can
interact with this guy this guy can
interact with this guy and these can
interact with one another and every time
we add a cubit if we were to add a
circle here let's say we added this
fourth qubit right here we noticed that
every single one of them can now
interact with it we have to draw lots of
these lines